one of the
criticisms of
Islam points to specific verses of the
Quran and the criticism being that it is
not a religion of Peace can you speak to
that so objectively speaking if you were
to take the verses of the Quran about
violence and compare them just from a
purely percentage based comparison to
the New Testament and the Old Testament
you would find less verses about war in
the Quran than the Old Testament or the
New Testament and there are plenty of
studies to speak to that deeper than
that contextualizing the birth of Islam
the revelation of the Quran which was
over 23
years in response to deep persecution of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
makes it very clear that none of those
verses are what they've been made out to
be if Muslims believed that they had to
kill people wherever they are uh mankind
would not exist there are two billion of
us right if if we believe that we were
called by the Quran to hurt people and
to kill people uh simply for being
non-believers right it
would not make for a sustainable world
so Islam is not violent and I think that
the history of Muslims also Bears
witness to that the history of Islam is
a history of contribution is a history
of building is a history of medicine and
science and
math and of course Muslims have
sometimes fallen short of Islamic
standards in the past and in the present
but if you look at the overall history
of Islam and the history of the Muslim
Community that's not the case and when
you look at the
present you know uh Muslim Community
around the world Muslims do not account
for a greater proportion of violence
than other Faith communities and again
the word terrorist uh is a functionless
and meaningless word because uh to me
it's no less violent if it's commanded
by a head of state or by a
government uh than by a non-state actor
so Muslims do not account for a greater
portion of violence now nor have they
accounted for a greater portion of
violence in the past why do you think
these narratives have taken hold in
present discourse at least in in the
United States because they allow for
greater violence against the Muslim
Community domestically and abroad the
United States has launched Wars against
primarily Muslim countries right and has
a particularly violent foreign policy
towards the Muslim world and the Muslim
Community here in the United States has
dealt with unfortunately multiple
aggressive
iterations of programs of suppression
and surveillance under Republican and
Democratic administrations and so
there's a convenience to that
islamophobia there's a convenience to
that framing of the Muslim Community
that also distracts from other forms of
violence that are deeply pervasive and
present including the ones that are
committed by the government
itself